[Music]
well let's talk about some hurricanes so
hurricanes natural disasters they cause
a lot of problems around the world one
point sorry 153 point nine billion
dollars of damage in 2016 alone no one
is immune to weather emergencies right
our people prepared right whether it's a
hurricane or it's a tornado or it's a
flood or snow storm everybody needs
something right and sometimes people
need a lot of things but what do you do
right you go to the grocery store the
shelves are empty you go to your local
hardware store and you need a tarp for
your roof and they could all be gone
right empty shelves don't help anyone
there's a lot of opportunity around this
how do organizations and businesses
change the way they operate so they can
quickly react to these types of storms
to meet people's basic needs right you
can obviously there's chances to
increase revenue is obviously chances to
lower transportation costs a lot of
times in these scenarios supply chains
get disrupted and you end up paying
what's essentially the same thing as
overnight shipping to get your product
to your stores and it costs a lot of
money and then you also have a chance to
make a real difference in people's lives
and you've a chance to really have a lot
of increased customer loyalty you can
really win customers for life if your
organization's can get this right but
obviously it's not easy right there's a
lot of real-world constraints that come
into play here right you don't have
every product that you need in every
store in every distribution center like
I mentioned logistics the costs are
expensive and there's often a very short
window of time if you're talking about a
tornado or
a wildfire you'd have hours maybe of
notice and in the case of a hurricane
maybe you're lucky enough that you've
got a couple days and so an organization
has to be able to react very quickly but
you also don't know which products you
need to send it in how much and when so
that's what we're going to talk about
today so quickly who are we we are North
Highland we are a full spectrum
expertise management consulting firm
mid-sized located in Atlanta Georgia and
we go to market across four different
service lines customer experience
performance improvement tech and digital
and transformation with these eight
capabilities and the three of us
presenting today are in the data and
analytics capability okay how do you
respond to this as an organization right
didn't come out right so we're talking
about a model today right we're talking
about a predictive model and with any
predictive model even if it is the most
accurate model in the world somebody has
to do something with that number right
somebody has to operationalize it and
make it happen and for a large
enterprise there are many components
that have to be pulled together to make
that happen right product prediction s
we're here to talk about today but other
things such as ownership and decision
making who is going to say if that's the
right amount of product to send to a
store all right what approvals have to
happen having some kind of central
command where people are all in the same
room to make these decisions very
quickly all the different trends and
freight issues around diverting freight
from different locations
having contracts in place for for
shipping in these situations so you're
not paying spot market prices obviously
communication and visibility is very
important IT system uptime right
everything runs on a system if you can't
get these orders plugged into some kind
of system it's not going to result in a
truck roll and store offs Raziel
resilience
is a big one right so if you've got a
store out there the hurricane just went
by and in the roof is ripped off how do
you know are you are you people going to
be able to show up if they can show up
and your store is intact customers are
gonna start showing up what happens if
you only have a some of your employees
show up or their home helping their
families right what if they don't have
power all these things happen and so
people need to prepare for it and
finally customer engagement if you can
do hyperlocal
communication with your customers to say
which stores are open which stores are
closed what products do they have what
products are they waiting on you will
definitely resonate with your customers
ok the business case there's a lot of
opportunity here we looked at a number
of investor calls throughout the the
last number of years where there been a
lot of hurricanes and you can see there
are big numbers we're talking about 360
million dollars of hurricane related
sales in 2011 I believe that was
hurricane sandy second quote significant
demand on the transportation system and
cost went up these are this is the
c-suite of of very large companies
hurricanes Harvey and Irma drove demand
and our team sent over 11,000 truckloads
of product for two storms in two cities
two states to take that one step further
to talk about the the actual revenue
impact so this is from the end of last
year again for Irma and Harvey different
retailers and the impact it had on their
revenue you can see you've got a lot of
home improvement companies up at the top
clearly they have a lot of revenue to
gain and then you've got some others
lower on the bottom there where maybe
they don't such as Macy's and Kohl's
don't necessarily sell a lot of
generators or tarps or flashlights and
batteries but they are impacted just the
same maybe they need to work on their
store offs resilience or come up with
their there are transportation plans
where
they need to adjust those to reduce cost
but that is not what we really came to
talk about today we want to talk about a
little bit the technology and here to go
into the prediction is my colleague
Charlie Moore how did we make this
happen how did we build a model that can
effectively predict demand in near
real-time based on very confusing
situations on the ground
well Google cloud platform has enough
tools to make a system like this
possible to build everything from a big
data platform data warehousing system in
bigquery and cloud storage to the
machine learning tools that are enabled
through cloud cloud ml tensorflow
scikit-learn and caris on top of that to
orchestration layers like kubernetes
that let you run massive processing
loads at a moment's notice that can
scale up and down and be efficient in
their processing it gives us a very
easily deployable maintainable highly
reliable system that we can work with
one of the biggest problems that we had
coming in and we knew we were going to
run into this was getting all the
weather data if you don't know where a
storm hit almost exactly how can you
predict hyperlocal demand for hurricane
moves by 50 miles you might be sending
generators to the wrong store so you
need to understand exactly where demand
is going to be by understanding what the
weather is there's a big problem with
that though turns out when a hurricane
hits all of the meters and sensors that
the National Weather Service has out
there fail they stop reporting accurate
wind speeds they stop reporting total
rainfall and you just get nulls in your
data set actually NOAA has a great data
set that's available for free and Google
bigquery we looked into it and it turns
out during all of the key hurricanes
that we were interested in training on
there were big old blanks in the data
but no it does provide real-time
forecasts and you can get current hour
forecasts that essentially reflect the
reality of
the ground but those are in an
interesting file format and they can't
just be dumped straight into a database
so we need a processing tool that we can
use to get the data from NOAA into
bigquery so how do we do this each file
is programmatically named based on the
time the forecast that it's running as
well as the the number of hours in the
future that the forecast is for because
if something is happening right now oh
sorry about that if if an event is
happening right now we want to be able
to understand the impact in the future
as well so we we can generate a URL from
the date time that we're interested in
predicting and download from NOAA and
process that in actually it's a Fortran
library that has existed since I think
1982 so we need a specialized
environment that can run Fortran we
can't just run this in a node App Engine
or something like that then we will dump
the results into a CSV and stream those
records into bigquery 24 files per day
for 10 years results in about a hundred
and fifty billion records that we're
having to load in order to train the
model so we used docker and kubernetes
in this case to do our deployment
strategy there are a lot of different
technologies you could use to do this as
an organization is moving into a cloud
environment they're gonna have
guardrails put up right you have to work
within the constraints that are set by
security and reality on the ground and
kubernetes was a really good tool that
was in our allowable toolbox here
so we developed Python programs two of
them actually to just do the quick
streaming and land in kubernetes now if
you've been to many talks this
conference you've probably heard about
kubernetes and most of the talks are
about kubernetes as a micro services
handling layer you can deploy a bunch of
different micro services into kubernetes
and they will scale up scale down that's
actually not what we're doing here we we
only have two services in this and
neither of them are micro we're just
using kubernetes for raw computing power
and we don't have to manage anything so
we have a Redis pod that we spin up that
has a list with all 10,000 files that we
want to download and we spin up about
500 different computers each processing
task is very small so we only need the
g1 small compute engine type it's very
inexpensive and we can actually make
those nodes preemptable as well to lower
the cost even further Redis gives us a
very fault-tolerant system to work in
it's very fast and this is all the code
that it took to spin up two jobs one on
the left you've got our Python script
that's going to do the downloading and
processing and on the right is just an
example of how you would spin up the
kubernetes cluster that's pretty much
all the work that we had to do from the
management and orchestration side it
saves a lot of time it it's really clean
and nice to work with and you don't have
to know MapReduce which is also nice so
that's going to come up in just a second
to talk about the details of how we do
the prediction but just to give you an
idea of what we're predicting we're
looking across 300 product categories
for a retailer and we're trying to
understand what is the change in dollar
demand in that category you know if I if
I want to buy a mop how much is the
total dollar demand going to increase
well you might have multi packs of mops
you might have single packs of mops
multi packs of bleach so by distilling
it to the dollar level you're able to
get a good insight into what is the
actual consumer need in this area how
much products do we need to ship if we
look and this is a noisy graph but I'll
explain how it works if we look at the
way demand actually works in a store
the blue line is the the real customer
demand these are people coming and
knocking on your door and saying I want
to buy something from you
a traditional replenishment system is
not fast enough to respond to that
demand because leading into an event you
will have what's called pre-strike where
the the demand is increased immediately
before the hurricane comes I I bet a lot
of people here have gone out and bought
flashlights or batteries right before a
hurricane is coming just in case you
lose power additionally you're gonna
have a second demand spike when the
event really happens and that's the one
that's really hard to respond to and
predict the yellow line that you see
here is the amount of days of stock that
a traditional replenishment system might
leave you with ordinarily it works well
it keeps you around you know whatever
baseline you set for your replenishment
system it keeps about that many days of
stock on hand maybe you get a shipment
every two weeks of mops but in these
severe events that demand is gonna
increase
way too quickly and you'll very very
quickly be out of stock you won't have
what you need on the shelves for people
to buy and then then you'll have too
much after the event your replenishment
system has caught up and now all of a
sudden you've got two or three times the
inventory that you want to have on hand
from mops this may or may not be a big
deal but think about a high-cost item
like a generator if you ship a pallet of
generators to the wrong store you have
inventory that you can't sell in the
wrong place that you may have to ship to
another store that actually needs it but
by then it might be too late people
aren't buying generators anymore because
their powers turned back on and so now
you've got a bunch of extra stock that
you either have to mark down
significantly or send back to the
distribution center or something like
that so we looked into how we can
predict this and we came up with a lot
of options we looked at traditional time
series analysis
we looked at linear regressions things
like that none of those can handle the
scale and volume of data that we were
considering we really needed something
that could be rapidly scaled up and
accurate across the depth of data that
we're looking at to give you an insight
into the modeling techniques that we
used we're gonna bring up Matt Yates
who's my colleague I had a lot of energy
around this project just because the
opportunity to really impact people's
lives to to meet people at a time of
need and it was a lot of fun too because
we got to really be on the the bleeding
edge loved interacting and working with
Google cloud platform this was one of my
first interactions and so I think the
the two themes that that we've heard
about kubernetes about machine learning
and AI at this at this conference really
continue on and we we really experienced
the benefits of those things as we'll go
through here so just gonna give you a
sense of what our pipeline looks like
here is we had to build out a ton of
features in order to be able to give you
a accurate prediction so we've got
features in here we'll talk to go into
really detail around around what we're
doing there but we've got kubernetes
pulling in that weather data we've got
bigquery which is housing a lot of
internal company data we Rob menteng
that with census data and some some
other really rich of open data sources
putting those into models training them
tins are flowing Kara's have a little
bit of socket learn in the pipeline
there as well and the pre-processing and
then ultimately all of that gets wrapped
up into an output prediction so let's
deep dive on some of these on the actual
features whether we knew right away
we're gonna have to collect that we went
in and got billions of records put them
in bigquery was able to roll those up
into a store grain store hourly grain in
bigquery in a matter of minutes so
you're talking about terabytes and
terabytes of data billions of Records we
sort of
arranged it into store using trade area
zip codes so we needed to go from an
individual weather dot on a map to a zip
code assigning it to a store and then
rolling all of that up to a store hourly
actual or forecasted weather and
bigquery handled it effortlessly it was
spectacular
beyond that we went out and got in LCD
data that's national land cover database
it's a governmental agency that
publishes basically they go through
satellite imagery turned that using some
regression tree or some classification
tree models into information around
what's the tree cover like what's the
impervious surface percentage at any
particular point at a three millimeter
grain across the US they also have
really rich I think as a teen category
data set about for this point on a map
is this high urban density low urban
density is it you know is it ice or is
it a farmland so some really rich data
around what is happening on the earth at
a particular point and we were able to
aggregate that up at the store level to
say what percentage of the stores trade
area is covered by farmland versus
high-density urban housing and that's
gonna make a difference in what sells
ultimately following a storm census data
widely available
you know population densities holding a
lot of really cool information from the
census as a potential feature and then
inventory sales data from our client so
one thing that really wanted to point
out here was we did almost all of our
feature engineering in bigquery and I
absolutely loved working in it with it
sequel worked 95% of the time we found a
couple of instances where we wanted to
use JavaScript in a user-defined
function so I've got a little example
here our project was beyond hurricanes
so this is a tornado example but it
would be pretty difficult in sequel
alone to given a latitude longitude of a
tornado find all of the stores
with potential impact from that tornado
find their distance ranked the distance
take some pretty complex geometry
trigonometry I had to go back and
remember some stuff from high school to
do this but I was able to create a
user-defined function call that
user-defined function in sequel and
create some really complex calculations
right on top of bigquery very fun stuff
so then once we did our feature
engineering we needed to train those
models we went in here thinking we could
sort of create one model to rule them
all so we think we're thinking RNN so we
have some time series we're thinking
multi output so we have all these
product categories let's break them all
in a single model we experiment with
that we were able to to get a skillful
model it was about twice as good as a
naive model of just a moving average so
if a moving average model said you'd
have $200 worth of sales and you know we
might be $200 off for that and our model
with our rnm was able to predict that
twice as well but we weren't satisfied
with that we thought you know we can do
better if we make the problem a little
more so ultimately we ended up creating
a just a a sequential feed-forward
neural network and actually dividing it
from multi output down to a single
output and then just creating a lot of
those little deep networks and and
calling them individually and then when
we when we create the prediction we can
call each of those models individually
in serial or parallel and we're able to
make those predictions for each product
category using a similarly architected
neural network but it just with the
discrete weights so initially we're
using tensorflow
we were feeding in the data in with a
cue runner and because with RN ends
you've got pretty complex data sets very
big data sets ultimately we found you
know if we want to try to make this as
skillful as possible let's try to
iterate fast so in comes chaos we're
able to iterate and try things out and
care as it's fully compatible with ml
engine which we'll talk about here in a
second so
we moved from pure tinder flow to to
Kara's library on top of that with the
tens of flow back-end to do some rapid
prototyping the way that we sort of
reframed the problem here is instead of
trying to do an RNN and a time series
analysis we said you know every one of
these events has a time zero when the
event actually happened we need to go
figure out what our baseline sales were
in the days coming up to that we need to
figure out what our pre strike sales are
if that's Act applicable and that's
something we might want to predict and
we also predict our post strike sales
and the good news is with a weather
forecast if I if I trust the forecasts
of the weather and I'm not trying to we
weren't trying to forecast the weather
we were consuming that from NOAA than
National Oceanic Atmospheric
Administration I can actually days ahead
of a hurricane actually hitting I can
give you according to the where the
forecast where's that hurricane gonna
hit and go ahead and predict post strike
demand right after that and then we
pulled the time together so instead of
trying to do a time series demand
forecast we said let's take all the
demand that's going to happen in the
immediate period following the hurricane
lump it all together and say after this
hurricane here's gonna be your demand
level and it's gonna be spread out
across time but we're kind of divorced
the time element from our problem we're
able to get a more skillful model that
way so then once we got our architecture
how we wanted it we use type of
parameter tuning an ml engine another
brilliant feature of Google cloud and so
here we were able to to tune and sort of
search the grid search our batch size
learning rate number of layers the shape
and size of our layers and our
activation function to find the optimal
most skillful set of those two to make
our predictions so here is a slot that
we're really proud of so as we said we
have 300 different Radek categories
there the product categories are really
based on consumer needs so mops are a
category
dehumidifiers are a category where
you've got a lot of products that a
retailer might have within those each
category but we're predicting demand for
mops
demand for humidifiers and in the end
for our post storm predictions we were
able to get 90% of predictions within a
hundred and fifty dollars daily average
error meaning and that's based on a
holdout set meaning you know if we
predict it's gonna be 300 dollars in
sales 68 percent of the time it's going
to be between 250 and to 250 and 350 so
pretty accurate there we were really
pleased our client was really pleased
with the accuracy on the holdout set and
you know I think that's a function of a
lot of time spent and feature
engineering data pipelining as well as
the power of deep neural networks and
then ultimately I think the one of the
major challenges here and you'll hear
about it in all of the DevOps or m/l
conversations is actually getting this
deployed and operationalized ultimately
this is sort of a structure we think is
the the best to keep this going on a
long term using container registry
kubernetes obviously source control big
queries where all that data lives and
then we stored out all of our models in
care as an H file format to cloud
storage we're able to call those back
and make those predictions in really
almost real-time I mean if each
prediction takes seconds to make and
that's you know the interaction between
cloud storage and bigquery and your
compute environment is really seamless
there
so I'm gonna call but damn backup he's
gonna talk about how do we take these
predictions and actually make them
operationalized on the ground
thank you Matt okay so we've got a very
accurate model now just putting out
numbers that that we we believe in and
that we're ready to take action on so
back to my point earlier great how do
you fold this back in what do you do
with it right a lot of things have to
happen still first of all person still
has to be in the loop here right like
any model this is a this is a prediction
it has a confidence to it and the
confidence can be high or low
so somebody needs to say this one's this
one's wrong we need to change it there's
also other factors that come into play
maybe the prediction is right on but the
DC doesn't have the inventory or there's
a an event coming up at the store next
month and they don't want to sell all
the inventory this month a lot of other
factors that come into play the model
doesn't know everything right person's
got to be involved and then once the
person approves it it's got to get out
the door right so it's things like how
do you fit it into your ERP system to
cut a purchase order um how do you then
get it on a truck right you've got to
you know you might be shipping your
company might use pallets or you might
use cartons right how do you get the
right number into those units and on a
truck and out the door all right there's
a lot of a lot of rounding that goes on
in these scenarios so I thought I would
walk through an example again all of
this is done in bigquery so say like we
mentioned before we're doing sales at a
category or a grouping level right in
this case I'll use generators so let's
say for a store we know that we're going
to need $10,000 in generators and we say
that because we don't necessarily know
if it's this particular generator that
people really want to buy or that one at
the end of the day people will often buy
whatever generator is there if their
power is out and so we we predict at the
group level but we ship at the
item-level right and so we've got to get
this down to an item and there's lots of
ways to do this to turn this into an
individual skew you can do a number of
things it depends on your organization
so maybe you want to default to what
that stores customers prefer maybe they
really love the 5500 watt generator
right or maybe maybe we're talking about
another category say shingles we're in
in this part of the country they really
like architectural gray shingles but in
another part of country they liked and
shingles right and so you really have to
be able to fine tune which actual
products you're going to send to the
store obviously you have to check the
stores inventory maybe the store has
everything you need and you don't need
to ship a thing right so again we're
talking about bigquery taking this
prediction and going in real time
checking store inventory maybe they
don't have enough but there's a truck on
the way you've got to know that too
obviously maybe even after that you
still need some and so you have to see
if your DC has enough maybe your DC has
enough for your store but doesn't have
enough for all the stores that that DC
serves what do you do in that case right
then let's say you figure that out you
still got around for how many how many
do you put on a pallet how many pallets
do you put on a truck right maybe the
recommendation is you need what do we
say here you need two pallets of the
5500 watt well maybe that was 1.9
pallets that you really needed you're
probably going to round that to 2 right
you're not going to slow the truck down
you're not going to slow this process
down to get that right you're gonna move
and go alright so how do you handle that
logic very quickly supply chain
organizations do this stuff all the time
and the more we can help them get there
faster the whole faster this whole this
whole process works and so you see at
the end here the net skew sales
prediction ends up being significantly
different than what came out of the
model and so just to talk about data
volume here imagine for a law
company the size of the table that has
the SKU store inventory think of the
same thing for DC inventory think of the
same thing for POS right you've got to
hit billion row tables over and over and
over again and you got to do it fast and
bigquery was again pretty awesome at
doing it okay again so I'm on the how do
you operationalize this notion here so
so you take a model that's complex and
you you know we didn't build this to run
this forever we built this to hand over
to our client and so they often have a
varying range of skill sets and
knowledge about data science to where
you've got to tailor your solution to
the people who are going to receive it
also there's a complexity issue here
like we could probably get the 90%
accuracy up to 95 or higher if we baked
every single thing we could in the model
took everything into consideration but
then we risked it being so unwieldy and
cumbersome that nobody would even
remember what all these configuration
parameters were and so we had to
right-size it right and so these are
just some examples and so these are some
of the tunable parameters we call them
knobs we gave him a lot of knobs to turn
of how they can say you know what I want
to adjust this I don't want adjust that
to give them the right level of granular
control without having to crack open the
code and get their hands dirty they can
do that if they want but if they don't
they've got a very easy way to say you
know that last shipment we send it was a
little too much it was a little too too
little let's make some changes so you
see some things like max wind gusts
threshold right maybe there were some
events where we didn't really recommend
anything because we said they didn't hit
a threshold
well let's we could maybe lower that
number and more more events will pop up
and with that I'm gonna pass it back to
my colleague mr. Matt who's gonna show
you some demos so ultimately what we're
going to demo here is the end user
interface just so you can get an idea of
how this
be done in action most these numbers are
made up so they don't tie out completely
but just for client confidentiality
confidentiality purposes but this will
give you an idea of what we're looking
at we decided to use tableau for these
demos loved looking at working with
tableau for just a quick dashboarding
tool and so giving a sense of both how
do you look at weather data and
understand how it's happening on the
ground at a store how do you turn your
weather data into predictions and how
should you consume that as a user and
ultimately ultimately after you turn
those predictions orders how do you
track it so what you're looking at here
is the weather aggregated to a store
level this is actually for Hurricane
ARMA I believe so you'll see all the
stores listed there on the map if you
click on a store you can you can get a
data table here that shows over time
some key weather metrics so in this
circumstance wind gust here was 190
miles an hour on September 12th at noon
and that was that was actual for one of
the four keys that was the actual wind
speed we've got a suite of metrics here
from total precipitation temperature
vegetation rates soil moisture that you
could actually go through and look at
and understand what was happening on the
ground at each store so I play this for
you and you can actually see the wind
gust go up the coast and it's going on
loop here so you'll see it repeating
over and over and that is all wind gusts
that we consider to be an event that we
need to consider potential demand spikes
because of those events so then once you
know that you want to turn that into
prediction so what you're looking at
here is the actual event prediction for
an ARMA example 154 stores I'm gonna
drill into a single store here and we'll
look at you know for the for the
products that are affected for this
store the baseline sales that we would
have expected without an event 146,000
we think we're gonna get across all
these product categories 310 thousand
dollars worth of sales we only have 135
on hand
we've got 32,000 and therefore we need
to order two hundred nine thousand
dollars worth of product
that's turned down thousand on aggregate
product but it's split across a ton of
item classes so let's drill into
somebody's item classes and see what I
need to order and for a seasoned fans we
need order 95,000 there you can see we
need 1338 pallets and our mean
prediction error there is plus or minus
one pallet so if I'm a if I'm a merchant
and I want to be conservative about it
maybe I don't send maybe I'll subtract a
pallet let me out of Hallett the same
thing for tarps here our prediction
error is really good at zero on tarps on
grills not quite as good so we need 21
pallets and that's plus or minus two and
then let's drill in here on air quality
dehumidifiers so we need to send three
of those pallets plus or minus zero on
average so pretty good prediction so
this is the store typically sells this
30 watt version of that at thirty thirty
one percent of the time but then in
emergencies you typically send a 50 watt
so we we let the client choose you know
do you want to send 30 watt which is
typically sold in that store or you want
to send the 50 watt so I'm not gonna go
into the actual ordering process here
just for confidentiality purposes but
then ultimately we turn those how many
you need to order into an order form
that they could execute on their system
then once you execute that order form
you want to be able to track that data
and track those orders all the way to a
store so we built another dashboard that
utilized all of the orders after they
were placed all the way up until they
were delivered so some examples here of
you can drill in just like you can on
any other tablet - where we just saw
into a particular product category for a
particular store and see exactly what's
headed to that store in both retail
dollars and units this could be used by
the merchandising organization or it
could be used by the store to understand
what's on its way and with the delivery
ejs and everything else right there on
the page so wrap this up machine
learning plus a really deep
understanding integration with business
process made this a successful project
ultimately I think a lot of you guys
probably not in the same category but
there's something to be considered here
for the ability of how can you react
and appropriately respond to to you know
human emergencies whatever they may be
and help people and change people's
lives for the better so really
appreciate your your time listening
today we'll hang out over here in the
corner if you want to ask any questions
and that concludes our presentation
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]